but then I love you so much thanks for
taking me outside today
yes wery well a [ __ ] it I don't even
know what we're doing
front flip but there was a back flip
don't question me if I say it's a
[ __ ] crud flipping it as a front flip
whoa holy [ __ ] no nut up down no now it
stops betting place oh no all right I
can still do this
come in come in come in come here come
here
let's go ha ha ha no that's better no
all right son you see this [ __ ] you see
this front flip I didn't hear anything
but there you go sign your [ __ ] thing
how did I got you the first time holy
[ __ ] it's impossible
alright god damn it it's all your fault
I'm sorry dude I'm sorry no [ __ ] cash
and I've run my son does [ __ ] they can
do this come on SADS
bless your team spirit
you [ __ ] disgrace I don't care close
doesn't win anything I don't even know
how we're communicating [ __ ] I'm really
bad at this come on do I love you
can you pick me up again no hell I know
I can't really grab it anymore I
whatever it is pretty comfortable I
might consider let's try it one more
time
grab that [ __ ] no that's not how you
grab it I'm disappointed
oh no now you're doing best fat mass bah
come back here rush back that son of a
[ __ ] alright I guess I can practice my
sexual skills
this one's called oh yeah piggy slay
this one's called just take me take me
right well spot you read all he lacks my
sexual moves he's come here RESPA I know
you want me oh yeah oh yeah like these
movies back yes
no I'm sorry it's our best but don't
leave me I'm sorry I can change I love
you
front flap yeah guffaws you can do it
Hana [ __ ] he made it does it look like I
care baby I don't care look at my
bicycle that's the biggest oh I can
still do this I'm coming I don't care
about your victory you're not gonna out
match me does it look like I need a
hospital all right son we're on a trip
to the subway station you better behave
I'm sick of your [ __ ] and your
complaining I don't care about school
and stupid [ __ ] like that we are a
gorgeous don't question my logic we're
using the bicycle it's obvious okay shut
up that's not you
you're nagae as opposed to I hope you're
happy all right we're in the subway now
are you happy it's the first time you
actually take me somewhere uh you're
just full of [ __ ] aren't you just trying
to make me look bad in front of my brain
dad I think you can't sell one I don't
care he was fat okay mom
mom is kind of fat I know it's a [ __ ]
disgrace come on dad I think we should
go the police might come shut up I'm not
afraid of the police we [ __ ] made it
look look at you on that stupid poster
it shows how gay you are look at that
[ __ ] you're just you're a big [ __ ]
you just big [ __ ] left out I hate
they said I would make money I am the
one who pays for it just because I did
I'd advertise I don't care how the gun
my name is Peter back hope you enjoyed
this little happy wheels month I put a
lot of time here
so if you want to spare a second to give
it a like and a favorite I would really
much appreciate it
also be sure to subscribe and join the
brony why not give it a shot I do my
best to keep it entertaining and I also
thought I'd give away three of these
epic happy wheels t-shirts if you want
to win one all you gotta do is leave a
comment down below about whatever you
want and let's put my stuff hey comes a
breakfast